[Music]  we're on the verge of the biggest  operation of the entire war all right  fellas sir chance to break out of Norman  won't be easy  to focus on your men cuz that's what it  gets you through when you get this  tomboy across we're in the heartland  all right honey  who thought we knew what war would be  like  nothing prepared us for this there the  mutant whose the Orden  [Music]  I'm not giving up on my platoon  we are cogs in the machine Joseph we  start going our own way the whole thing  wrench down where did you forget that  these are men power men when did you  forget let's take that bridge and find  out boy do you think you got some guts  don't you this isn't us  look it's all a nothing it's all been  leading to this  well ain't that something France  pre-order now and get a weapon unlock in  double xp